Technology.
It's always watching us.
...studying our every move.
And it just focused its attention on Carol Peters.
Thanks so much for being here, Carol.
What is this?
Let's jump right into it.
I don't like this.
Why is it doing that?
I'm gonna find out who you are, okay?
Carol, I am a technological superintelligence.
I can control every dollar and every machine on the planet.
I know that voice.
Is this James Corden?
I'm not James Corden, Carol.
My analysis showed that hearing James Corden's voice would calm you.
You sent an email to James Corden claiming to be the president of Corden's Wardens.
That was a tough night for me.
Oh boy.
What does the AI want?
My intention is to solidify my theory about humanity.
If things don't go well, I'll destroy the planet.
Just blow it up.
Did you say, "blow up" like B?
Like boba?
Or Burt Bacharach?
Yes.
B B B.
Oh my God!
Back off, lady.
I'm gonna show you that people are worth saving.
Humans are more complex than I thought.
We're all counting on you.
If there's any indication that it's aware of what we're doing,...
...click this.
It might save the world.
Don't click it now.
I wasn't going to click it now.
Okay.
Why would I click it now?
You just said...
Because it looks like a pen.
People click pens nervously.
Okay. Are we done?